晚上好
今天是情绪
神月快乐
情人节快乐
买了好
对 七七快乐
对 本来叫情人节快乐
七七快乐
买了好
有个东西 我好像没有拿
这个是很重要的
好久不见 我还好吗
好
对 晚上好
七七情人节
没猫病
对了 我在找这个拿过来
我在找这个拿过来
一会儿 反正就是
这个是情话首饰
我还没拿来
那千
计划首饰
我还没有拿
这个很好
看王子
王子
对
我那个视频叫王子
叫王子还是差距的
长脑子的意外
特别好
差距叫差距
对
我最开始是叫王子
还叫差距的
上次见我
还在上次 按摩一下不需要摸
不需要摸
今天可能会说到
说到一些东西
因为但是我在直播间里
说这个东西的话
不可适
因为我只有一说
就会断掉
所以我们会有两期
我们有两期
一个是今天的晚上
一个是明天晚上
今天晚上直播
我们讲学习
明天晚上的话
明天晚上是个放谈
明天晚上不在
不在哪儿
不在我这儿
明天晚上不在
不在独一
明天晚上我们晃个地方
明天明天晚上会
会和重揚资本的
一个合会人做放谈
明天晚上7点
晚上是明天晚上7点
所以这是两期
这两期
所以今天
不是今天人不多
我一直人不多
我已经没有留两个
我现在两个
我两个
对 明天是在另外一个地方
明天直播在那儿
明天直播一在那儿
我在这儿没法直播
一直播一说就会断的
对 一直梁梁送给我
我刚才说了
我没法说
我一说就断了
你们还想看我直播吗
我一关就关啥里边
对吧
我一关就关三个里边
你还非要问我
你说咋说
我怎么说
今天讲学习
怎么学习
我认为这个很重要
本来我先讲讲怎么影响来的
影响也可以讲
但是我突然讲讲讲
大家讲讲怎么学习
因为对我来说
所以我来说
其实我成程说过
一个东西如果不是特别需要天赋的话
我先去学做来的几
我不觉得今天需要需要很多
我反而觉得
我反而觉得这是一个
非常美好的时间
我那个傻去哪
我反而觉得是一个非常美好的时间
对
今天是聊学习
你切的原计呢
今天聊这个
我特别想聊这个
在能那什么的地方
所以好的都会知道
已经已经老会打到屏幕上了
对今天可以聊月度
可以聊月度
可以聊月度可以聊学习
差的是啥
差的是个批演
我吃批演呢
我有批演
差的是批演
一个经由
可以很多到我一问
我说今天按摩一下
就把按摩按摩按摩
这个世界无限没好
我只要做自媒体和投资吗
不一定
所以我来说所有的事情都是在
帮助我自我进化
如果一个东西能够帮助我自我进化
那就很好
有两个东西
第一个东西呢
就是我需要有一部分生存的钱
这个生存的钱
给我花了
我不用再为钱发酬的时候
那我剩下次考的问题
就已经好了
可是我一旦进化了
什么程度的时候
我不就不需要去
对吧
你明白我意思吧
我就不需要去花那么多时间
和静美
只是一个相互相传的过程
这本书
这本书算是个礼物
他是和初学者
他是和你通过这本书
理解
原来这个世界是这个样子的
对吧
反正如果你是个高手
你不是和看我的书
高人就不要看我的书了
他会正顺你的三顿
对不对
你会觉得我讲的东西
你都知道
我讲的东西
而且你讲的可能比我还讲的
还好
所以高手就不要看我的书
高人就不要看我的书
大师也不要看了
你想得生那份问题
对吧
所以你觉得
我就是个普通人
我想开过师也
我想知道怎么
你不一步做事
那我觉得这本书
我就等还是可以看一看的
我这本书还是可以看的
我还是觉得还不错的
对
明天的哪儿啊
有老婆就告诉他
明天的哪儿呢
我就不说的
对
我这本书是和
我这本书是和小白
就是十个小白
对
老婆已经说了
超级冰又回来也说了
这都老婆已经
对
小永也说了
主的书价也说了
对吧
这都是老婆已经
所以我就不说了
明天七点
在哪儿
老婆你们已经说了
那是啥意思
那是个爱朋友
来我
那个啥
我们
我给大家发个小东西吧
我给大家发个好玩的东西
然后怎么开始
好玩的东西
才没想
然后
好
什么玩没有
没有